Amber Rose
one thing Amber Rose open invite to come
on the show I'd love to have you on this
couch right here yeah open invite to
Amber Rose guys go blow up her Instagram
and DM her okay next is doing mind your
business
that is wrong that is wrong
[Music]
right you said that in your freestyle
good and you want to know why not me no
but you said that in your freestyle no
what would I say can we replay it can we
replay the freestyle I could just say it
okay
I could just say it but I heard what you
said that's five thousand type of way no
I said
we'll get all the views violence
stupid new challenge
a whole lot of ignorant dudes on the
news while in chicks Book for 2000 Post
the new style and think about it having
no Talent that's the new Talent
I saw a chick on red carpet I said tell
me what you do she said I'm pretty pass
click titties belly button too I twerk
for the gram my videos get Hella bunch
of views that's very [__] cool but
tell me what you do it's disgusting they
say hoes women why
why is it disgusting because you're a
hater men are haters that women make
money and go get booked for 2 000
because they're [__] pretty no don't
hate the [__] hate the consumer
but he's saying it from an observatory
yeah and you're observing a [__] making
money
wait wait wait wait wait hold on let
that [__] twerking check this out
though check this out look am I tripping
check this out now what about what about
when you did that what about the girl
when she did that right so I got the
2000 right for three months right now
but then she was gonna get 10 million
from this company but they've seen her
do that [__] and said nah
dollars
all right I got a question if you knew a
woman was gonna make 10 million three
months from then he knows that who knows
the future of fortune teller you know
somebody that was gonna give her the 10
million how about that but my whole
thing is
for the past three months
without nothing and don't conform
because they know what they're gonna be
later
you want somebody
thank you
[Applause]
let's face it
becoming approach Raider will take years
but you don't
blessing we don't got premium yet
oh okay is that it
oh there's more okay bring it back up
then
possible to even
oh there's not more
okay are you gaslighting me okay
should would you be okay
with your brother dating a woman that
has been publicly linked to rappers
entertainers
and Ballers for the last decade
dating it depends on what concept was
she's been known to date multiple
different you know like she dated Kanye
Future
um
I don't know
the rappers maybe Eminem maybe you know
Tristan Thompson you know the rappers
the entertainers
10 years
because it's public knowledge it
probably would bother me however she
wasn't famous she could have done the
same thing I just wouldn't know about it
because she's not in the Limelight but
if you found out she was doing that in
your town would you be okay with it
maybe they're not the famous ones but
like the town rapper the town baller
probably not I probably wouldn't like it
no you wouldn't like it what about you
no I wouldn't like it I wouldn't like my
brother dating someone knowing that
she's basically been around you know
his choice I wouldn't like it I'm going
to tell them about this down to a minute
do you think we should judge women for
sleeping around
um
if it depends if I feel like you
shouldn't judge anyone based on anything
if it's their decision that's what they
that's what they want to do
um
again if it's to if it's a crazy
magnitude then everyone's gonna have an
opinion on it but
I don't think it's anyone's business if
anyone sleeps with to be honest okay go
ahead
yeah I agree because
it's not I don't feel like it's not nice
to judge people to be fair especially
based on how many people they've slept
with and whatever they're doing it's
their business so I don't really feel
like it's something that we should be
judging them on
yeah obviously we should we shouldn't
judge but we're humans and we always
have opinions and says and stuff like
that so
is what it is I'm a human I would judge
you
I will judge even if I try not to judge
I know that I will judge
do you think that shaming women would
lead to better outcomes like if women
shamed each other more like if we said
strippers or [__] you know I'm not
gonna you know strippers are [__] if
you sleep around you're a [__] do you
think if we said that publicly if the
older generation said that to us if
everyone was saying that do you think
women would act differently or just be
quieter about it no because it happens
on a daily basis and if anything I think
it makes women Rebel even more
um oh you oh come on you think in this
culture
women are shamed for sleeping around
yeah and I think if that's what's made
things like only fans and things like
this become such a right thing because
it's like women are taking it as like no
they're it's to some women they're
empowering themselves by doing this I
think the more you shame someone and the
more you try and
say something's wrong is the more people
want to preview preview different but
don't you think that only fans is a
reward in a way
like how are they ashamed if they're
getting millions of dollars a month I
mean I know
a lot of girls are bad at only fans I
know they're not all making that but you
see what I'm saying yeah 100 but you
still means that there's still some
people that will see that content or
will know about it and go on their
social media and
um speak about it and judge someone
based on it so it's always whether what
you get paid and what you get what
someone says to you is two different
things okay what do you think I feel
like in this day and age and in this
Society I just feel like people are very
sensitive to comments and
you know judging people so if someone
was to shame you and if more people were
to shame women and that I definitely
feel like it would
it would it would stop or decrease oh
yeah what about you yeah I think
definitely if we were just a little bit
more vocal and had that old school
mentality about women respecting
themselves and cherishing themselves and
um sex being a little bit more sacred
definitely what do you think Auntie
public shaming
billboard type shame I think that's what
it's going to take and for and for like
single mothers of multiple baby fathers
I think they should be posters there
should be posters yeah nowadays they go
if you go and sit on shops and you still
they've got like special websites in
there and like post Billboards and
newspapers and milk bottles shame them
all on there put them all on there if
you know a girl's got a high body count
and she can prove it put on shame or put
a picture up on the milk bottles and
stuff I think it should be everywhere
this girl's a [__] you drive past on
the bus do you know this Hall that's
what you should have well do you know
this 304 look or are you the father of
one of these children you know with the
mother with like 10 different children I
think it should be ashamed publicly
because they're doing everything
publicly so I'm not showing them
publicly